nearly two years into the pandemic many
countries are once again ramping up
covert restrictions in response to the
rapid spread of the omicron variant in
the u.s hospitals and health workers are
bracing for an expected surge after the
holidays and across the atlantic large
parts of europe are reimposing partial
lockdowns to curb record numbers of new
cases
rounding off the year with another
variant and another set of measures to
fight back
countries across europe have tightened
restrictions dampening planned new
year's eve celebrations as omicron
spreads
france has announced a range of new
measures including reducing the weight
for booster jabs to three months
the government will also vote on a new
bill to bar the unvaccinated from entry
to places like restaurants and cinemas
[Music]
today we have adopted the following
additional measures
which will apply from next monday for a
period of three weeks
to slow down omicron large gatherings
will be limited to a maximum of two
thousand people indoors and five
thousand people outdoors
across the channel cases are soaring as
omicron takes hold as the uk's dominant
strain
new restrictions have caused confusion
with northern ireland scotland and wales
tightening rules while in england
authorities said they would wait and
reassess in the new year are you finding
this day one of new restrictions again
here in northern ireland i am slightly
bewildered i don't understand them i've
come over from scotland
so everything's different
in the us omicron has caused chaos for
airlines with over two hundred thousand
daily infections nationwide crew
shortages have grounded planes
but president joe biden said the
vaccination drive meant the u.s was in a
better position than in previous waves
of infections
america had made progress
things are better
but we do know that with a rising cases
we still have tens of millions of
unvaccinated people
and we're seeing hospitalizations rise
it means our hospitals in some places
are going to get overrun
but in terms of equipment both in terms
of equipment and staff
on monday new york city brought into
effect a vaccine mandate for nearly all
private sector workers
proof of vaccination is also needed for
most indoor activities like eating in
restaurants
strict measures that officials hope will
keep the city fully open as the world
crosses into the third year of the
pandemic
peter jing hong is an infectious disease
physician and a professor of medicine at
the university of california he joins me
now from san francisco
doctor covert cases are on the rise in
the u.s not surprisingly hospitals are
bracing for a spike after the holidays
new york has even introduced a vaccine
mandate for businesses as we've just
seen sensible sufficient moves by
authorities
well michael the answer is yes and no
uh it's kind of like putting out a
forest fire with just a few buckets of
water but you can't blame the biden
administration this caught them by
surprise many people thought they put
all their eggs in the vaccine baskets so
nowhere trying to diversify with more
testing
ppe
additional labor uh it may be good for
some parts of the country like the west
coast where it's not as bad but
in the east coast it may be too little
too late
us health authorities as you well know
have eased quarantine recommendations
from 10 to 5 days is this a further hint
that omicron is a less severe corona
variant
i think that's partially the answer
michael but
i think the cdc was motivated to do this
really because of a variety of factors
one
there was a lot of political pressure
because of uh workforce that was taken
out for
probably an outdated quarantine uh 10
days or isolation of 10 days
but is also a nod to the fact that there
is some evidence that the incubation
period for for omicron is much shorter
three days compared to
four days for delton five for alpha for
example but many people are worried
because again the tail end requires
that people wear masks for the the
additional five days after five days of
isolation they have to have no symptoms
and there's no testing involved so
there's a lot of sort of like
you're on the honor system after those
initial five days right
uh here in europe and around the world
we're seeing countries reintroducing
restrictions including new lockdowns and
reinforcing the the imperative basically
to social distances you're a doctor so
all politics aside is that alone what we
should do to minimize if not eliminate
the spread of this variant
well i think michael again it's so hard
for europe right now because it's in the
middle of the thunderstorm and you're
trying to repair the roof so it's almost
all hands on deck so one thing isn't
good enough uh vaccines isn't good
enough booster uptake has been quite as
good as people had hoped again tick
everyone by surprise
i think testing isn't as quite as
emphasized in europe rapid testing at
home say as in some parts of the u.s and
of course we can't even get testing to
buy anymore they're all sold out so i
think as many things as you do as you
can will mitigate the damage that's uh
already in progress that's a dr peter
chin hong in san francisco thank you sir
for your time and your perspective
here's a roundup now of some more
developments in the pandemic australia
recorded another record surge in cases
as an outbreak of the highly infectious
omicron variant disrupts the planned
reopening of the economy
turkey has also seen infections spike
according to the health ministry new
cases rose by 30 percent that's the
highest percentage rise so far this year
and indonesia has detected its first
locally transmitted omicron case the
patient had no recent history of
overseas travel was asymptomatic and now
isolating at a jakarta hospital
tougher curbs on public life also went
into effect in much of germany today
several regions have tightened
restrictions on public gatherings and
access to public events ahead of new
year's eve thousands took to the streets
overnight to protest covert restrictions
mostly in germany's east clashes erupted
in a number of cities with at least 10
police officers reportedly injured
but other people have been flocking to
vaccination centers for their booster
shots germany's government is urging
people to get vaccinated as the viruses
omicron variant spreads
even during the festive season thousands
of people are getting their job like at
this vaccination center in berlin
at the moment more than 70 percent of
the population is fully vaccinated and
around 36 percent of all germans have
received a booster shot
right now we are barely giving any first
shots in vaccination centers up to 98 or
booster jabs people who come here are
already pro-vaccine and have actively
sought out a vaccination
people turning up here for a booster
shot believe it's the key to ending the
pandemic
i think it's good the more people who
get vaccinated the better it is for all
of us that's why it's also very
important for me
it's super important i think it's very
very important i'm a bit worried that's
why i'm here yes i've been here
i got it because my job is important to
me and i come into contact with a lot of
people the booster and my health are
important
germany has introduced new social
distancing measures and restrictions
under the so-called 2g rule only those
vaccinated or recently recovered may
enter many venues and events
under the 2g plus rule people also have
to show a negative test result on top of
that
thanks to these measures germany has
managed to halve the number of
infections per hundred thousand
inhabitants between the end of november
and the end of december
we'll also be here over the new year to
vaccinate people because we're in a
really critical phase
we're in a situation
where every day counts
and where it's better to be vaccinated
today
rather than tomorrow
authorities fear a new wave of
infections due to the omicron variant we
not only hit the population hard
particularly the unvaccinated but could
also affect the running of critical
infrastructure such as hospitals and
other public services
you